hi Nikki hi Jennifer hello I'm Logan
hey I love this movie so much have me in
tears by the end which I wasn't
expecting so I loved it
um you know Jennifer you are so good in
this movie you played this Deadly
Assassin who will do anything to save
her daughter as a mother yourself how
overly protective do you think you are
with your kid I I'm not an overly
protective Mom I'm not I'm not that type
of Mom I'm kind of more the mom that's
like roots and wings I'm like giving
them a space where they know that you're
loved and I'm here and it's solid and
giving them space like I I like the
balance of that you know
um
this character is like
the extreme uh
case obviously because of the
circumstances right she has to give up
her child at the beginning of the movie
so that is something so unimaginable to
me
um and so uh it we're very different in
uh in a lot of ways but the same in the
in the visceral sense that we would do
anything to protect our children
I love that
I love that I'm sure your kids
appreciate that too but you let them
kind of do their thing yeah they love it
all right now that they're teenagers
it's like leave me alone
is that hard for you as a mom now that
they're teenagers and they are kind of
off doing their own thing oh my God so
hard it's so hard it's the worst thing
ever I talked to Nikki about it because
your kids are a little bit older just
just a little bit Yeah and mine's yeah
we're just getting into being teenagers
and I'm like what is happening
they don't want to hang out with me
anymore
besties like we were in bed every night
I'm watching movies and oh and it was
hugging and kissing and now it's just
like you touch them and they're like
no you're absolutely right but if you
were an animal you would pick them up
and you would walk them out into the
desert and you'd drop them and you'd
leave them there and they would have to
grow up by themselves yeah and but we're
not we're human and we want to just keep
holding on to them no and we have to let
them
have a little bit of space and so
yeah I listen I'm not a mom but I just
remember my mom saying when we turned
teenagers that was the hardest thing for
her so I I've heard that before you know
with the weapons training and the fight
training and learning how to ride a
motorcycle in a snowmobile how
empowering is a role like this for you
it's very empowering you know I would
think I would have got a role like this
when I was in my 20s and to get it now
is even like triple empowering right and
so
um doing all the fight training being
this much of an action kind of you know
movie star in a move in a big Global
movie like this is is exciting it's
exciting for me and uh
um I loved it I loved doing the training
um I'm I'm in good physical shape and I
got in better physical shape for this
movie
um I had to you know learn all the
choreographed fights and did them on my
own and you know it was me and Joe
fighting up there uh the two of us and
um using the knife and doing the whole
thing and learning how to shoot and and
that's who she was and that's what the
role required so uh it it was it was
actually kind of that part of it because
it's make believe it's fun
yeah just as I'm wrapping up who do you
think would win in a showdown your
character and the mother of Ben
Affleck's Batman
oh
you know they have a lot of special
effects in Batman
against a mother I mean he's a superhero
against the mother whose child is being
threatened no chance oh you have a point
you have a point
I love that answer thank you so much so
nice I love the movie thank you so much
thank you